sup guys welcome to a brand new video
and just because I want to get this
really done and super quick we're about
to be seeing is a video posted from
Ubisoft that I got from skate from
GameSpot so huge shout out to them for
having this video on their channel
basically the video explains that
Ubisoft is coming out with new seasons a
new post launched off their season past
I'll just let you watch the rest of it
so anyway guys that'll be the end of it
I'll see you all later peace out and
enjoy this video
the four on our team is already hard at
work developing new heroes and content
that will be released during each new
season of the war between the factions
the faction war is really in gaming
attrition of the never ending war
between the night thus my and the Viking
it really acts as the cornerstone of our
personal schedule every free month we
have a new season of the section we're
in it will be the opportunity to
introduce new content each season we'll
have two you need heroes with a
dedicated set of weapons and play styles
plots free for all players each season
will expand the world with two new maps
to fight for control of
we'll continue to enrich an add
additional content to begin to the Year
code from day one every hero will be
able to advance the reputation level
unlocking new ways to customize the play
style and look of your warrior free
update will expand the progression of
each with new tiers new weapons new
armor and more increasing the number of
competitive builds for all heroes free
updates will also add new features in
gameplay modes beginning with
tournaments and ranked mode coming later
this year
with the season pass get to unique
heroes released at each season with one
week early access plus exclusive
benefits content and more for honor is
there for the long term we are very very
excited to share with you everything we
have planned moving forward the war
starts February 14th and it is just the
beginning